okay
we're back on overtime
okay here are the questions jamie in
your new book you write that ronald
reagan's administration proved to be the
gayest of any
presidential administration
yet why is that
uh just the sheer number of gay people
working in it did he did he know
well um
actually one of the big scoops in the
book was that in 1980 three weeks before
the republican national convention it
was brought to the attention of ben
bradley who was at the time the editor
of the washington post the allegation
that ronald reagan was being controlled
and i'm not i'm not lying here that he
was being controlled by a
homosexual network of right-wing
anti-communist gays
it could be they were controlling him as
a manchurian candidate and the po and
the washington post investigated this
they sent out bob woodward was one of
the reporters several other reporters
they investigated it and they did find
that there were some
gay men working for reagan but the
notion that this was some sort of
conspiratorial isn't it no plot when the
log cabin republican started it sort of
started two years earlier actually in
california when there was a ballot
initiative to ban gay school teachers
and reagan actually came out against it
and reagan was really decisive in
defeating it actually in 1978 and log
cabin republicans of course refers to
lincoln yeah who was genderfluid um
maybe i mean there's rumors he shared a
bed with a man for several years on the
american frontier which was not that
unusual in the 19th century although if
you read the letters of the exchange
with this guy they're pretty hot and
heavy so right um
he also went to the tonys every year
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh crystal cnn's new boss wants the
network to steer away from sensational
hyper-partisan coverage yes i saw that
cnn
you can't say you can't refer to the uh
election as the big lie or trump's big
lie as the big lie which again see i
mean i'm totally on the page of it was
the big lie but i think that's the right
thing yes i mean
now you're msnbc
even though
it's sort of like jack del rio he's
totally wrong but i defend his right to
be wrong okay do you think cnn will
actually stick with this new plan no i
mean they actually
listen
my issue isn't actually with uh opinion
journalism if you're upfront about what
your lens is what you're no problem with
that whatsoever i do have a problem when
it blinds you to
facts and honesty and i think both cnn
and msnbc their maximalist ideas in
terms of russiagate didn't end up
working so that's the issue i have there
will it work no because ultimately
what's going to happen trump's going to
come back guess what's going to rate the
people who go you know the furthest in
on trump that's what's going to get the
best ratings this is a business it's a
business model i think it's an abhorrent
one that leads to a disaster for america
i think it's a cancer on society all of
the cable networks but ultimately those
are the incentives they respond to so no
i don't think so what do you mean by
maximalist ideas about russia like the
p-tape stuff you know msm dossier msnbc
floating that he's been a russian asset
since 1985 oh that sort of i mean
the senate intelligence committee which
is controlled by republicans
said that trump's involvement with
russia was a grave national security
threat okay but that's not the same as
saying putin has a p tape and servers
are bouncing back and forth p-tape was
always lured and who knows i mean right
if you don't like that one then let's
talk about the lab leak and the idea of
where the coronavirus came from and the
fact that these outlets said that not
only could it no way
i have that issue every week on this
show yes
yes i'm gonna have an issue with opinion
journalism but the idea that russia and
trump were inappropriately intertwined i
mean his campaign manager manafort
was getting sharing polling information
with this guy kalimnik who was
the mueller report
found that there was no collusion and we
were promised this we were promised this
for three years they over promised and
it was really in in cable news but there
wasn't nothing that was every day there
wasn't it was something there was well
there was something it wasn't you know
what the truth was bad enough with trump
correct why did they have to embellish
it you're right why did they have to
embellish it what was what what he did
in public was bad enough right we
disqualified him for the presidency
right he said that maybe crimea should
maybe russia can keep crimea that to me
how about was about siding with putin
that too at helsinki right like uh my 17
intelligence agencies tell me one thing
i got to go with you
vlad it was a disgrace but they couldn't
just side with america is that a big ass
the problem with so many people in the
media they couldn't they couldn't
take that alone it had to be this
baroque conspiracy going back to 1987 he
was recruited by the kgb right i mean it
was just it was it was such a scandal
actually when you look back on it how we
were deluded by this well we were sold
the reality was we're not the same yeah
but since he doesn't care about he's a
clinical narcissist our standard
i know but but the idea that he would do
that is completely believable and he
would have done it well that's that's
why people bought it but if you're if
you're in the news business i mean
that's right i think cable news is such
a cancer is because ultimately right it
is just about the ratings they don't
care they got it wrong they're never
going to correct me
so is that going to change with the new
boss no and it's just about saying the
things that make your audience go yep
yes i already believe that thank you for
reinforcing what i've never letting
anything outside of the bubble inn and
that's fox news that's msnbc exactly
yeah okay uh danny if you could write a
screenplay about the 2020 election okay
so right i was going to ask you this
game change
okay that was about 2008 and sarah palin
sure that was great loved that
my boy woody harrelson was a great guy
great great guy great actor okay the one
the other one you did recount was about
the 2000 election
so yeah you're kind of due for writing a
new election movie yeah
so this question is what would you title
it and are you thinking about doing that
we got to do uh uh romney obama first
though that's the real action
is
mitt romney
[Laughter]
uh yeah i mean look uh
the problem with doing a trump movie
because the guy who directed those two
movies jay roach and i uh have been
talking about it for years is every day
is crazier than the day before right so
how do you how do you turn that into a
piece of drama that has something to say
that doesn't become you know irrelevant
the day after you start writing it right
and he could be president again and then
there's a new movie and then put you in
guantanamo bay for making videos
exactly
thank you everybody i appreciate you
coming
you